hi I'm Max Keiser this is the Kaiser
report is it real or is it fake should I
stay or should I go now is it real or is
it fake that's the question of our age
that is actually a very genuine question
is wrestling real or fake this was on
the Digital Spy they asked and the
answer yes it is real and it is fake so
I want to use the analogy it's hard to
be a wrestler you know it looks easy it
looks like it's all fake but in fact
it's hard to breathe through this mask
and of course some of the greats good
guy versus bad guy fights of World
Wrestling Entertainment
remember it's entertainment Stone Cold
Steve Austin vs. Dwayne the rock Johnson
obviously doing the rock Johnson was the
good guy and Stone Cold Steve Austin the
bad guy now the rules of the game are
the good guy always has to win right the
good guy wins Hulk Hogan vs. Andre the
Giant that was back in our day
Hulk Hogan versus Macho Man Randy Savage
so the good guy always wins and the bad
guy loses well the analogous situation
happened in America in 1996 a bit after
back then WWE so we called WWF World
Wrestling Federation and in 1996 we saw
the birth of MSNBC and Fox and this is
the WWE the wrestling entertainment the
bread and circuses for the American
population right according to Glenn
Greenwald New York Times says that
Russia Gate obsession saved MSNBC and
enriched its on-air stars but the
disappointing conclusion in which
nothing that their host promised
actually happened caused ratings to
plummet as confused and disoriented
viewers turned away on mass it's both
real and fake right which is the classic
recipe for propaganda propaganda works
when you mix in some real with
fake so it actors you to think that wait
a minute that's real and then it lead
you to kind of associate what's real
with what's fake that's propaganda
that's how it's done that's the whole
recipe that goes into it so wrestling is
fake but it is athletic I mean there is
a lot of athleticism that goes into the
performers who are out there and jumping
around falling on their back you know my
favorite is mankind who took a chair to
the face many many times and I think he
really you know suffered severely
because it's real
however the script is you know
pre-written right there's no shock at
the end of it because it's a form
formula of entertainment and a good
story and cable news whether it's Rachel
Maddow she plays the the he'll know I
think Fox plays the heel so Sean Hannity
is always the bad guy he's always like
the Andre the Giant in this situation
and Rachel Maddow is really more of the
whole Colgan character so they go at it
every night and it's quite exhausting
after a while because if they you know
to make it exciting sean hannity should
put on a dress and do MSNBC every once
in a while and Rachel Maddow should put
on some camo you know and put on some
you know heavy weight lifting gear and
go and do Fox every now and then just to
get some variety to the entertainment
because it gets very very stale well I
think it's even more than just those
presenters they're just presenters and
the gladiators fighting are the various
right or left Red Team Blue Team
gladiators the politicians the lobbyists
the you know all the deep state who are
heroes presented on MSNBC they're former
FBI officials and they're former NSA
officials and they're former Department
of Defense officials and they go on
television and they say yeah we're gonna
get that trunk guy he's no good and he
colluded with the Russians and then
behind the scenes we saw with the the
revelation of the actual under oath
comments that they gave in Congress was
like yeah no we have no evidence but
they went out there to entertain the
masses and the masses want to hear these
stories
they do you think anybody goes to WWE
and there it's a four billion dollar
industry people go there cheering it on
do they you think they don't know it's
fake and that it's not staged and that
it's not scripted but they go there
because they know for certain the good
guys gonna win that's what has to happen
right well Rachel Maddow she failed in
her storytelling she scripted this and
the bad guy won I like it didn't he
wasn't defeated the bad guy Trump wasn't
defeated by this Muller thing and all
this stuff and it came to a
disappointing end and the audience is
kicking over the chairs as they're
leaving they're like this sucks this is
a horrible game right wrestling is is
more about soap operas with sweat and
blood and Rachel Maddow is about a soap
opera for Housewives where she never
stops crying right so she's always like
right which can get boring after a while
and you know this is unfortunately that
what we have to understand or
fortunately to understand Donald Trump
you have to understand his connection to
the professional wrestling and the WWE
yeah because he was featured in many of
the bouts of WWE and he was a reality TV
star but he also had huge cachet with
the huge business that is wrestling and
he understands the simplicity of that
story good guy bad guy so China is a bad
guy we're a good guy or whatever the
context might be and he presents it to
his audience in those very simplistic
terms and which is not to say it doesn't
necessarily connote descend you descend
jewishness diss essentially to send you
annuity you know because Ronald Reagan
who was considered the the Great
Communicator was also very simplistic in
his messaging right and he would use the
Hollywood scripting technique again
using the stories from basic Hollywood
soap operas he was in soap operas or he
did advertisement for soap operas being
a Ronald Reagan convinced people that
smoking was healthy right well I'm
Ronald Reagan smoking is great for your
health because of this ability to
propagandize remember propaganda you mix
the fake with the real
do you get propaganda mixing the fake
with a rail so Hulk Hogan Andre the
Giant you know they never mistook
themselves from real wrestlers you know
even though you know some of their moves
like the camel clutch or the gory bomb
you know these were hard things to do
and they did get hurt they genuinely did
get hurt so it felt like maybe they wore
a wrestler or maybe they were a boxer
but they never they knew they had to
follow this script
they knew the good guy had to win they
no matter how how hard the gory bomb was
but what has happened with the you know
the entertainment of the cable news
networks is sometimes they confuse
themselves they believe that they're
privileged journalists class that
they're like you know these hardscrabble
journalists seeking out the truth when
all they're doing is giving opinion
shows and they're entertaining the
people like with and it's you know it's
right left it's red and blue like MSNBC
versus Fox they formed it the same exact
time it's like bread and circuses and
you know they formed in 1996 and it's no
coincidence that within a few years then
we saw the dismantling of the wealth
creation of this nation because it was
the bread and circuses it is the bread
and circuses because even if the bad guy
is winning which is the other team if
you're on the red team it's a blue team
if you're on the blue team it's the red
team that there's always hope that the
next election you're gonna get in and
you start cheering your team and so
there's always hope they keep on hanging
on to the hope while that that other
side is plundering but it is doing well
as entertainment this is the headline
that Glenn Greenwald was talking about
it's hard being a Lucha Libre
I had a Lucha Libre mask on you know
yelling like that is hard on your throat
it's record readings and record chaos on
cable news was the New York Times
headline subtitle cable networks are
facing threats and opportunities in a
national crisis now Fox is fighting back
and CNBC is looking to the right CNN is
defined by Jeffrey Zucker and he may run
for mayor they're talking about this
this whole set up where not only has
MSNBC failed in their storytelling
because they they built up their
audience that the good guys
twin and they didn't so you know we have
a situation of a standoff but they're
profiting from chaos well that's another
term we could throw out there yellow
journalism right Hearst Newspapers I
believe he said something like you give
me the war I'll give you the headline or
I'll give you the headline and then you
give me the war I think that's what he
said
so it's it's which comes first the
headlines of the war so we know leading
up to the Iraq war that CNN was the
primary reason for the first Iraq war
the first invasion remember Stormin
Norman yeah that was back during George
Bush one remember that and that was that
was a clear example of a network
starting a war with a sovereign country
and so that worked so well for CNN they
made so much money with that that they
started a few more Wars that Hillary
started you know destroyed Libya for
ratings and now we've got we've run out
of countries to destroy in America
because the only countries left at
America can invade could actually fight
back so we'll never do that so instead
we're attacking our own population for
ratings so you know Rachel Maddow is
like look at those people dying on the
street by our weapons
let's call pause for a commercial break
right it's I mean she's a propagandist
so is Fox News and they're also war
profiteers it's entertainment and it's
also human rights violation at the very
end of the day they're entertaining you
they are the bread and circus remember
bread and circuses is not from the top
down what juvenile meant when he said
that and I think was a second century BC
in the Roman Empire he said it's the
population they're abandoning their
civic duty they're abandoning it by
being distracted by bread and circuses
so they love these gladiator fights and
by the way the gladiators were highly
highly paid and they were you know owned
an expensive property of those who they
owned them so they weren't actually
killed as much as they were they had a
fan base each of them and they fought
and that you know they provided the
bread and circuses and lurking in the
background for all the networks New York
Times says is the question how long can
this last cable news appeared like much
of linear television to be in terminal
decline before Donald Trump turned it
into the greatest
terrifying show on earth so we're
trapped in this situation of you know
two teams fighting at each other while
at the top they're plundering they
continue to plunder their focus perhaps
on some of the looting down on Fifth
Avenue but the fact is while we're
absorbed we the people absorbed in our
whatever one we are loyal to MSNBC or
Fox the plunder continues while they're
doing their job you know they don't get
paid thirty 40 million dollars a year
just to read headlines right they get
paid to assist in the wealth
confiscation and destruction of a once
thriving nation by the plutocracy that
will soon be gone and nowhere to be
found
just like in other countries that you
have a disappearing plutocracy in the
past I want you to teach me some of
those moves you mentioned earlier what
was the flying camel drop or so the
camel clutch
what's your that's your thing I want to
learn the camel clutch glory bomb we
entertained you but who is the who's the
who's a good guy who's the bad guy here
I'm clearly omnipresent in all
situations I'm both good and bad I gave
you the truth today the truth tomorrow
that makes me not a propagandist but a
freaking journalist stay tuned
[Music]
welcome back to the Kaiser report I'm
Max Keiser time now to turn to Isaiah
Jackson he is the author of this book
that is literally on fire all over
America bitcoin and black America Isiah
welcome back to the Kaiser report oh
yeah thank you for having me back beyond
that this is an awesome moment in the
history of Bitcoin because we've got
coast to coast protests out there black
lives matter movement is gaining
enormous traction and a lot of people in
the crowds are holding up a big sign
that says Bitcoin and black America by
Isaiah Jackson read this book tell us
how you feel about all what's going on I
say it honestly it's overwhelming
because it's organic it's really the
people doing it I didn't for the record
I didn't pay any protestors to call with
signs so it literally is just people
taking pictures and sending it to me and
the scope of where is that I've seen in
New Jersey Raleigh North Carolina London
the fact that it's international now is
is very promising so good to see and I'm
glad people are focusing on the
economics that can come after the smoke
clears and of course you know I have a
long history with Bitcoin as a matter of
fact on page 12 it's mentioned that a
notable white man named Max Keiser was
basically telling the black community in
America to buy as much Bitcoin as they
possibly could because they could buy
the white community of course back then
it was only a dollar or $3 but you say
in the book you don't agree with that
sentiment per se but the point is that
in America there's a lot of talk about
the reparations movement there is now
you know 7 to 14 trillion dollars
floated about as we need to you know
legislate for reparations for slavery in
America we we have the residue and the
legacy of slavery in America to this day
the America is still an extraordinarily
racist country and that you really can't
say anything diff
than that how does Bitcoin in the
economics of Bitcoin how does that
really liberate the black community
finally in America Isaiah I just want to
say first your statement I understood
exactly what you meant but yes also you
know I do want to point out that we
can't build our own communities and the
way Bitcoin can help is economically we
need leverage and I believe that as an
asset class also as a payment system if
you can create a circular economy
sometime in the future and also have big
point as leverage for your community
that's something that you can use in the
future much like any other assets that
people buy so if you buy real estate
same thing those things are are
leveraged for you to be able to get
policies in place to have the money to
support yourself and have strong
communities where we can basically have
the police that bother us out of there
because economically it doesn't do
anybody any good and I think that's one
of the only ways defeated is
economically being able to do it and I
think Bitcoin can help - keywords
associated with Bitcoin one I'm
confiscating all so a lot of problem
with the black community in America is
that their wealth is constantly being
stolen in 2008 during the highest
housing crisis the predominant victim of
that fraud perpetrated by Wall Street
were the black communities number two
another phrase that you hear with
Bitcoin is self sovereignty so again
black community America has never truly
been invited to be part of America black
communities still seen as outside of
core American society so here you have
self sovereignty effectively the black
community could secede from the white
community in America get their own self
sovereignty become financially
independent with their own currency
called Bitcoin and it's uncomplicated
bull you know cops can be you know
knocking down your door they're not
gonna get your Bitcoin Isaiah absolutely
and I grew that completely I wrote about
it in the book there are many examples
of black communities that have been
formed we have black Wall Street and
Tulsa and Wilmington in Georgia we've
had different places so those
communities can be built and also like
you said I'm scalable if you can't take
it away you don't have people knocking
on your doors taken away your gold or
burning it down as
seen in our communities before can't
burn down Bitcoin so that is not able to
happen and also like you said being able
to be so sovereign is important because
there are communities such as in LA
Koreatown Chinatown Little Ethiopia I've
lived there for three years that are so
sovereign in that small community and
they don't have any problems I'm not
saying that it solves racism but
economically they whoever if somebody
messed with their business is amiss with
the people that work there or in that
community they would have to pay for it
and that's what we have to start doing
they even pay for it and removing
ourselves on a broader scale black
community and every community has to
start removing ourselves from this money
system that funds our own terror my
observation growing up in America is
that the Democrats tend to pander to the
black community with giveaways free
phones and this type of thing and that
seems to be the opposite of empowering a
community and helping a community become
self-sufficient and I see Joe Biden the
Democratic nominees once again pandering
like a fool to the black community
except this time it seems like the black
community is on to the Democratic tricks
and they're not falling for him this
time and they're going to go down the
path of hard money and that's what we're
talking about in your own personal
journey which you document in this
excellent book Bitcoin a black America
available on your online bookseller I
suggest you buy a copy immediately as a
matter of fact buy 10 copies and give
them to all your white friends so that
they'll know what's happening what's
coming soon with black community in
America but the point is that my
question is your personal journey into
Bitcoin is also a journey of hard money
where you have been able to describe
what's happened to you because you've
become kind of a new person in a way
over the past five years or maybe I'm
it's that correct I said can you
describe that absolutely I have over the
past five years
once I started focusing on the economics
and the actual root of our problem which
is the Federal Reserve constantly
printing money and inflation keeping our
our dollars
invaluable that was the root of the
problem that led me down the bigpoint
path and I just you know at a certain
point in my life about about five years
ago decided that if this is a solution
it has to involve the black community
because on the broader scale of the
world there are more black and brown
people in the world then there are white
people so when people think about you
know who to pander to in my community
I'm like I'm focusing on my community
because around the world we have so many
different cultures that could adopt a
point and that to me was the root of
most of the problems people have if your
money is bad whoever controls the money
controls you so once you take away that
control I just combine those things and
it took me down this path where I'm at a
point that that's pretty much all I'm
focused on and yes it has changed me for
the better
Bitcoin has increased in price so that
has helped with the marketing side of it
but I still want to make sure people get
the why a big point why you needed why
you should use it and now that people
are starting to realize that with our
the you know resale pricing I think this
is a perfect storm so glad that I made
that change and glad to be working with
people like yourself this is a good time
now for people to understand the money
part of it hard money right as you point
out every country has the the society is
stripped in two different classes class
Society in America obviously you have
the black community is kind of a
perpetual underclass because of the
politics that goes back to slavery days
but other countries have similar
dynamics going on and lived in France
for many years and the Arab community in
France is considered to be a permanent
underclass in the country of France for
example and you find this in countries
all over the world class systems in
Britain of course you have a permanent
underclass of non aristocrats of non
Oxford Cambridge going university types
that are treated poorly throughout their
entire lives all of these groups all
over the world
who are tired of being having their
individual sovereignty and an agency
destroyed with paper money by adopting
Bitcoin they can self actualize and
become real strong and on that note I
wanted to ask you about George
Floyd of course was murdered for the
alleged crime of passing a counterfeit
$20 bill
I mean what's remarkable to me Isiah you
know it all comes back to money right
here's George Floyd who was murdered for
allegedly passing a fake $20 bill
murdered by the state that just printed
a counterfeit six trillion dollars to
bail out Warren Buffett to bail out
Jamie Dimon well the irony of this is
disgusting
Isaiah you said it perfect the irony is
is crazy even when I heard the story uh
you know immediately was thinking I made
if you play with digital money or
Bitcoin you don't have to worry about
counterfeit ever again you don't have to
worry about these problems and you're
right but people that you actually pay
to protect you are the ones that ended
up killing him over something as small
as a chunk between our bill we've seen
this with other cases as well we've seen
killings of people with handcuffs people
killed in their home while they're
sleeping all of these things are
disgusting and I am NOT saying that
bitcoin is the savior of police
brutality
however what I am saying is well you
only control your communities it's much
harder for police to come in and take
that wealth away today
now it has you know some things have
happened in the past but at this point I
think the black community strong enough
to realize that and I think with the
George Floyd killings the uprisings that
will happen have been beautiful to see
because people are tired and I think
it's a perfect storm it's the summertime
people are broke they're unemployed
college kids are out of school people
don't have much to do and they just
focus on the fact that and after you
know this is over what am I gonna do
money-wise so I think that's something
you know good to focus on but shout out
to the protesters out there doing
anything yeah I mean just talking to you
now I had an idea
all protesters all over America should
print the QR code to a Bitcoin wallet
with five or ten bucks with the Bitcoin
still cops who are attacking them can
quickly download that QR code and put
five or ten dollars a Bitcoin into their
wallets and and cops immediately would
switch from fiat money bandits from
agents of the fiat money corrupt state
to Bitcoin revolutionaries just put that
QR code forget the signs that say you
know down with the cops or cops are bad
just put a QR code give them a couple of
bucks a Bitcoin and change the
they think because they're being paid in
Fiat and they're all going to go
bankrupt very very quickly now to quote
Saul Williams one of the greatest
artists of the 20th and 21st century I
love his music he put out a song
recently or a few years ago which he
said he's got a list of demands and
which is a brilliant song trying to get
Saul Williams on Keiser Report now for
five years I hope he hears this and will
respond to me and come on the show but
going forward what would be on your top
you know a list of things that you'd
like to see changed in society because
it is a hot subject now of course we
need a police accountability that has to
that has to happen at the very least
there should be police that are you know
telling other police hey you doing a
terrible job you need to fix whatever is
wrong with you of course I think we need
to adjust the judicial system because
that is a part of West aching without a
hundred to one sentences on things like
the drug bill and crown bill that came
out by Joe Biden who is running things
of that nature there's a lot of reform
and these apples to start with arresting
and convicting the police officers that
killed George Floyd reopening the cases
of racial violence let's start there and
then economically what I want to see is
after this is over people start to see
who the enemy is the state the state
dollars and how you can go banker or
will go bankrupt eventually if you
continue with this and to separate is
something that a lot of people have been
discussing in the black community and of
course is nothing against any other
community we just have to build our own
and you can't only rely on Bitcoin but I
think that is what in the future will
help us the book is Bitcoin and black
America Isaiah Jackson as the author
thanks for being on the Kaiser report
thanks for having me max all right
that's gonna do it for this edition of
the Kaiser report with me max Kaiser and
Stacy Hubbard like to thank our guest
Isaiah Jackson author of Bitcoin and
black America if you want to catch us on
Twitter
it's Kaiser reports the next time bye
y'all
[Music]